(upbeat music)
I'm constantly star struck by the people I get to meet
and apparently, they feel the same way too sometimes.
Check this out.
A time that I was starstruck.
Very funny story.
I'm hanging out with Will and family
and we are on this little boat.
We're in Miami and we get to, you know,
another boat and I realized, oh, we're going to that boat.
I turn around and I'm handing Willow off to someone, right.
So I'm taking Willow off the boat and I'm giving Willow,
she was young at the time, right.
And I turned around and it's Tom Cruise
and I've got the total dumb look on my face like, oh snap.
So it was Tom Cruise in the middle of Miami Harbor.
You know what, we all freak out over someone
at some point.
(upbeat music)